citizens of the reject nation we have
got ourselves an official trailer for
the secret invasion i'm excited to check
this out johnny tell us how you're
feeling i'm not the real johnny oh my
god i fooled ya he's
edge how are you i'm the real andrew i
think or am i
i've created a monster
this bit has not gone over as hilarious
as we were hoping today ladies and
gentlemen leave a like that would be
very much appreciated also a citizen
king t-shirt right now available at
shopzeroedition.com if you want to pick
yourself up one today any let's get to
it
[Music]
i
it's a close encounter yeah yeah exactly
for years
you've been avoiding earth
i have called for your help plenty of
other times and you've been pretty
content to let those calls go straight
to voicemail maria hill back
yeah well
this is different
how long has he been gone for how much
you know about your security detail
what do you mean how much do i know
about roadie
ross
nice
we're going to be very careful yeah tell
us
wowee
oh
that lies before us
this is just the beginning
this is my war
alone
and i'm the last person standing between
them
and what they really
this want great
and what is that
a little title
cool logo
where's the comedy
marvel i wasn't laughing that much about
the comments not mcu if you're not
laughing
it just it seems a little off to me
that was a great trailer
that that had
your favorite movies winter soldier yeah
i was thinking that the espionage it has
a real thriller espionage mystery vibe
to it that paranoia that fraught tension
of like who's who what's really going on
in this world and there's so much
mystery to unpack and honestly there's
this part of me that just felt really
happy for one of the highest paid actors
in the world samuel l jackson to finally
be getting like his le is like uh it's
the one he's leading he's he's leading
this one and nick fury's always been
supportive you know secret invasion of
course he would be but i'm excited to
see him like really get a chance to to
showcase those dramatic acting chops
again and it looks like so gripping as
much as it's a you know invasion of body
snatchers kind of vibe
in a sense right it still has uh a more
of like a grounded approach to it which
i was really really enjoying and not
just samuel l jackson but as john
pointed out the maria hill oh yeah yeah
their rapport together i'm really
excited to see like the more they bring
her in and things and and the more we
get you know further past you know the
little appearances before i feel like
we're gonna get to see some intense
badass maria hill more and more but uh
yeah this looked like the perfect blend
of a invasion of the body snatchers and
i just kept getting i know like winter
soldier espionage but like i was really
getting a james bond kind of vibe off
this trailer in particular which i
thought was really fun and yeah like
with sam jackson you're going to get to
see him probably do both you know the
scroll version and the self version so
not only do you have the samuel jackson
dramatic chops but i gotta imagine it's
gonna be fun to see him do two different
iterations of the character and like
olivia coleman in here too is like a
top-notch talent and i think she's
supposed to be some kind of old ally of
nick fury's and so i'm really excited to
see what their report like there's so
many like the the concept is super
intriguing but also the cast is just
dynamite and i cannot wait to see all
these people play off each other every
rod like ah like ah this is very
exciting yeah i agree with you guys it's
definitely getting that winter soldier
vibe and that was really interesting
that james bond uh
aspect that you threw in there but yeah
this looks really cool and i definitely
love the rapport that you mentioned
between maria hill and samuel jackson
they've got such good on-screen
chemistry and their interactions are
really seamless so i love that and i
love that we got ben mendelsohn back to
talos i already love to in this teaser
like we're already playing the game wait
who's that that scrolls out of scroll
obviously we know that talos has been
some of the other characters but i think
the thing i'm looking most forward to is
when i watch this the second third or
fourth time when you get those little
unique hints when you see like who's
revealed this squirrel is like okay that
was interesting they did point that
there were little uh hints and details
there that pointed out that might have
been a scroll or not so i'm looking
forward to that obviously this this
storyline in the comics is a very epic
storyline so i like how you mentioned
that it is grounded so i'm really
curious to see how they're going to get
that more grounded more like you know
it's not going to be as epic as the the
comic book story line was but i am
really looking forward to the fact that
samuel jackson finally gets to lead a
series because he's one of my favorite
actors of all time so yeah i'm really
looking forward to that and uh it was
awesome seeing everett ross back
freaking love martin freeman so good as
everett ross so yeah this looks really
exciting and yeah it looks great i gave
you two white [ __ ] a chance to shout
out rhodey
i gave you two watches
in this show rudy was great
we'll have him in the show he's probably
gonna set
he's going to have a better story to
tell than he did in the vendors age of
ultron and also we got our fa and we got
our favorite sarah connor in here emilia
clark yeah yeah
i don't know much about who work that's
the thing is like there's so much that
we don't really know about this because
like in the comic they they had so much
more fun with in the comic of heroes and
some of them are scrolls and i don't
think we're going to go like that big of
course here and especially to keep or or
maybe it could be like a crazy cameo
galore where you know you get all kinds
of people to come back just to be able
to play like a scroll version of
themself which would be a ton of fun to
do i just don't feel like we're going to
be getting that and i also feel like
with nick fury with their and perhaps
maria hell as well
we could perhaps see like some actual
kind of character arc with them because
you have nick fury here when it's not
exactly clear how long he's been off of
earth you know like don cheadle was
talking an interview not long ago
about like very very recent where
he was saying that with secret invasion
you know the we saw them introduced in
the 90s with captain marvel and they've
sort of been percolating ever since so
there's could be people here that would
had no idea this whole time they were a
scroll and it seems like there's such a
weary toll that has been taken on nick
fury over time and whatever that passage
is i'm excited to explore what that is
with his character and i i didn't think
that this trailer
that that's what i would end up be
the most anticipatory towards
is
samuel jackson getting a chance to
really do something refreshing with a
character he's been playing in in small
roles small like little bite-sized
chunks other than like avengers and
winter soldier he gets a chance to
really lead this time yeah and then
reminds you how good of a dramatic actor
he actually is beyond the meme and
beyond the fun of like oh he's showing
up and being sam jackson yeah he's he's
screaming at snakes on a plane maybe
they'll get let me say the f word this
show
my mother flipping earth
yeah no i mean i agree with you and um i
mean we'll see what happens i know the
the show's gotta like you know tell a
story line with the scrolls and all that
stuff but i'm curious to see if they're
gonna go a little bit non-linear
storytelling which show like where he
was up in space like what he was doing
how long the passage of time is yeah i'd
be really intrigued to see if they do
show that because i'd love to see that
yeah all right guys what do you think
about the secret invasion trailer i
thought it was pretty awesome we got a
world with my night one that we gotta
check out
and uh but other than that thank you
guys for being here thank you guys all
right well subscribe click that bell
leave a like
brian perry oh my god brian looking up
you on urban dictionary here's what we
got let's do it you're one of the
chillest guys you will ever meet
dude let's smoke a fatty together
because i i i do all day every day i
always have it never will stop
um it's my reputations you're chill
everybody loves being around brian why
because he's everyone's favorite and he
knows it i brian brian's a bit of a
cocky guy i love being around you right
now he's very confident in everything he
does like pledging he's hilarious tell
us a joke
will laugh because you tell it with
confidence
might not be funny but you're confident
like daniel the cook and has the most
beautiful eyes you've ever seen that's
true i looked you up on social media
and i just pissed myself that's why i
have a hard time finding love
it's my natural secretion
whatever i see i'm struck
i just have to secrete i have to be
spending time with o'brien is priceless
i'm sure we can afford you the cherry on
top is that he is a sex girl oh wow wow
romp between the sheets my god
leave you sore and in a spell for days i
want that brian perry after i want to
not be able to walk again i secrete this
here so there's peeing everywhere and
the other side as well yeah you know
well and vomit you might as well
make it it's hard for me to walk bruh
it's the luck of the draw these are all
facts
of your name this is what it says yeah
and i hope you live up to it because
that is some high stakes right there you
you could easily disappoint if someone
was like i'm going on a date with a guy
named brian let's see what brian's are
like my god
hilarious confident and right between
the sheets and this day yeah it's gonna
be a life changing a lot to live up to
man go all the way with brian geez good
for you i'm happy for you well done
[Music]